it's a tough choice New Yorkers have had
to deal with for years the golf club at
Chelsea Piers is closed but it's really
just an overpriced driving range
Bethpage is a world-renowned golf course
and it only cost $65 to play but good
luck getting there by public
transportation nymex trader Tom Schiff
after three decades in the pit saw a
market opportunity in the New York area
golf scene you can go to a regular golf
course you can take a golf lesson on the
range and they could work on you you
could read a tip-in in a Golf Digest on
how to treat your body but we get so
deep into it here we all come together
and we work on the crops form together
we need to do it in one facility one
stop shop into Wall Street shut-ins
willing to pay twelve and a half
thousand dollars to start golf and body
will get you back in shape and ready to
hit the links when it counts it's a 25
thousand square foot facility one block
from Penn Station shift gave us an
inside look at what it offers
state-of-the-art fitness equipment
world-class trainers that work with top
golfers like Luke Donald and Jason day a
private living room to entertain a fully
stocked cafe and seven high-tech HD golf
simulators berries equipped with
Trackman the leading golf radar that
cost $25,000 it gives data on your club
heads angle of attack and 3d imaging of
the balls flight Adam Scott's been in to
Train and Jimmy Fallon's a member but is
it a winning formula George Derringer
Managing Director at Deutsche Bank
started training at the 6th Avenue
complex last year and subsequently won
the British Amateur open I'm sure
everybody that is a member here enjoys
playing golf but I think that it's even
more refined in that everybody's and
ever here wants to get better at
playing golf this is the toolkit to get
better it's a value proposition that's
hard to resist for high rollers with no
time but money to spend and a drive to
play better we wouldn't be surprised at
Tom Chef opened more of these one-stop
shops in the near future